Hello,
and welcome to today's session. Today, I am
joined by David Simmons, head of developer relations
request DB,
and we are going to take a look
at Kubernetes.
How are you, David? I'm great. I love
the sig sig v there at the end
of your countdown. That's awesome.
Yeah. I wanted to do something that is
kinda geeky and took inspiration from the IT
crowd. I really like the their intro and
the ending where it's kinda windows crashes and
it it does that weird trailing thing. Yep.
But I I don't have the creative expertise
to actually do anything that intricate, flashing a
red banner on the screen.
I got that better. You got that better.
Yeah. I love the IT crowd too. That's
that's fantastic.
Oh, yeah. It's so funny.
So today's session, let's
let's start with a question actually.
In a word, what is your knowledge or
expertise of Kubernetes?
Well, the the word I would choose, I
probably don't wanna say on on a a
live private, but I
so here's my thing.
And this is why I sort of, you
know, talk to you about doing this is
I
understand
the point of Docker for the most part.
I don't like using it mostly because the
Mac version of Docker will suck the life
out of absolutely any machine
so far.
And so Kubernetes
is just, like seems to me to be
just extra Docker, and I don't get it.
Because I don't most of that, you know,
people say, oh, I'm gonna run, you know,
these 16 Docker containers. Like, if I tried
to run 16 Docker containers on this laptop,
it would die, and it's a brand new
Mac laptop. So
Yeah. I like that description. Kubernetes is extra
docker. I think we'll try and build on
that today a little bit. But you're right.
Definitely right. But docker for Mac, where it
is the easiest way to kind of have
a working Kubernetes control planning on a Mac.
The battery consumption is is pretty ridiculous. I
am very vigilant on closing it now
whenever I definitely do not need it.
So that's great. We're starting from essentially
a fresh slate and
you're gonna keep me right as we kind
of go through today's
I guess it's a tutorial of sorts where
I will do stuff with Kubernetes. You're gonna
probe me with loads of questions. We're gonna
try and get something working on Kubernetes and
hopefully,
I
have the ability to explain what the hell
I'm doing, which is questionable
at best, but we will see how we
get on. That's where the fun part is.
Yeah. So what I would say for the
people that are watching on YouTube, feel free
to liberally use the comments. If you wish
to ask questions, we will make sure that
we try and tackle them as we go.
So leave comments, we will address them.
I think what I'll do is just share
my screen and we'll dive straight in.
This maybe seems a bit brave,
but
there.
Awesome. Okay.
So this is just the Kubernetes website. What
I would say today is I am
I would say rather knowledgeable in Kubernetes. I
know what I'm doing, but I have not
memorized all of the YAML in the world.
So where I am not able to generate
the YAML for my Versus Code Editor, I
will be using the documentation and that is
okay. Nobody expects you to remember how to
type tens of thousands of different combinations of
YAML.
We'll just normalize that.
Then I was just telling somebody that I'm
mentoring. The number of times I still have
to Google, you know, how to do a
four loop in whatever given language I happen
to be using that day is ridiculous. I've
been coding for thirty years. So don't don't
ever let somebody tell you that you should
know all this stuff.
Oh, yeah. For sure. Definitely. Like, the longer
you do this, the more you forget, and
you always have to kinda look that stuff
up. It's Mhmm. Natural. In fact, I would
think people that are good at this are
people that are really good at understanding the
problem, but enough to ask the right question
to then go find the answer rather than
just inherently knowing the answer. Right.
Alright. So let's I just reset my Kubernetes
cluster, which is what the screen is here.
It's done. Now,
I am gonna type a few commands. I
don't and then we'll we'll backtrack a little
bit and talk about what Kubernetes is doing,
but
our main
way that we are going to consume Kubernetes
today is through the kube control command line
application,
which we can run on our terminal.
And the first primitive that we're gonna cover
today is a concept of a pod.
So when I run get pods, you'll see
that I have nothing. So that's just me
doing the whole magician sleeve thing. Right? There's
nothing pre running here. This is an empty
vanilla generic Docker for Mac Kubernetes cluster.
So let's back up a little bit and
I'll go back to just our nice little
talking mode.
As let's try and break down and understand
what we should cover as a backstory or
context first. So
containers,
the docker a bit of this conversation. Kubernetes
is a control plane for managing and orchestrating
containers across one or more machines.
If we were to explain a container,
then we have to kinda get down into
some Linux primitives.
So a container has a way of using
the Linux kernel to segment certain aspects of
the the process that is running to protect
it from the rest of the host.
Right. That maybe is that sounds a little
bit more complicated than I maybe intended it
to be.
No. The the container part makes sense to
me and and sort of having something to
control all the different containers makes sense to
me. But coming from you know, having grown
up in the the old world, you know,
client server,
you know, each
sort of server has its own
part in this.
A lot of what I don't get is
how how you can spin up extra containers
and have the rest of the containers know
about what's going on. Right?
And how this actually helps me rather than,
why don't I just have, you know, a
big server that can do this and and
call it a day?
Hi, doggy.
Yeah.
Rawkode. So you're comfortable with the container. Excellent.
And you wanna understand the sum of the
magic components of what Kubernetes is doing. Yes.
So with that, let's go straight into, like,
let's go into the pod one zero one
then. So
let me just make sure this is readable.
So
Oh, I have to save that as a
file. Okay. So
I'm on computer.
It could it it could entirely turn into
a a a live session of me yelling
at my dogs, by the way. Just so
we know.
That that's I'm perfectly comfortable with that. Don't
you worry about it. Now, I'm gonna just
quickly get this to as minimal as I
need it to be and then we'll go
through the different components of this. So
we can't deploy
a container to Kubernetes,
really. What we deploy to Kubernetes,
it's a primitive called a pod,
and a pod is a collection of one
or more containers.
So Okay. With with Docker, you could do
Docker run NGINX, and what that does is
it creates Linux name spaces and control groups
to kinda wrap that process up in its
own little bubble. Yep. But Kubernetes doesn't do
that. It actually creates the bubble and then
puts containers inside of it and it can
have more than one container that share the
same resources within that bubble.
I mean, I'm not comfortable with that analogy,
but it's what I just blurbed out my
mouth. So I'm gonna stick with it for
now. Okay.
It actually that actually makes sense to me,
which
is either really good or really scary depending.
Excellent. So
we've got a concept of a pod and
we can think of it as a container
for now, but it's it's
important to understand that it can be one
or more containers and it's not it's not
directly
mappable.
Now Kubernetes is all YAML driven.
You can use JSON, but you know,
that would be a bit cruel.
YAML is slightly a bit easier to work
with because we have the option of doing
comments as well. So
when we describe the YAML for any resource
in Kubernetes, so you know this format works
for every different type of resource that we're
gonna work with today.
Then generally what we have is an API
version and a kind. The API version and
kind perform or
they're like a key that says this is
the object type that we're working with. So
you know, imagine there was a b two
pod and a b one pod, although that's
not the These
two are directly linked and will very rarely
change.
We then have the option to pass and
submit a data. So you know, this is
just pretty much as it looks. We have
the ability to say the name of this
pod is going to be NGINX and we
can apply some labels to it, which allow
us to query those pods using our own
selectors from the command line. Okay.
So
while that is important, the start of that,
it doesn't actually affect what we run when
we apply this to the cluster.
To do that, we have something called a
spec or a specification
and we have the the most important key
in a pod is to list the containers
that this pod is going to have. Okay.
And we're only gonna have one for the
time being,
but this pod spec here, or this container
spec is very similar to what you would
do on the command line with a docker
container run or docker run command. Right. So
we can give it a name, we tell
it the image that we wish to run,
and I'm just going to give this a
hint that it exposes a port for us.
We're saying NGINX has a port 80 that
will be available where I can send requests
to this container.
And that's it.
So
that means that I can do a cube
control
apply.
We use the dash f, so flag
to say that we want to apply a
file
and I can pass in our pod dot
yaml. Okay.
And that creates a pod.
Now
because I know my muscle memory is gonna
kick in soon, I'll clarify that I am
very likely just to start typing key as
just an alias
or cube control.
Oh, well now I've just broken that alias
for cube control. What I
meant was that k is alias to cube
control. So I can really run get pods
and what we see here is that we
have a pod called NGINX, which is what
we called it. We can see this ready
but here it says one of one. That
means one container was in the spec and
we have one running and the status is
here. It has not been restarted
and it was created twenty four seconds ago.
So when you applied that pod dot yaml,
it not all it it basically it it
started that pod and started it running.
Yes. That is correct. So
we can go into the details of how
this kind of declarative approach works from the
API point of view or the or the,
you know,
We we can talk about how the controllers
within Kubernetes work if you want or we
can keep focusing on the workload a bit.
So that's entirely up to you. Let let's
do the workload a bit because that's that's
Alright. So we'll just go in the assumption
for now and maybe we'll we'll change that
later. But when you apply something to the
cluster, something creates that and it works. That's
I'm happy with that assumption for Okay.
So we have a few
a few introspection commands that become really important
when working with our Kubernetes clusters. So you
know, we've seen that we ran get pods
which gets me a list of pods.
I can also add a name to that
to fetch a single pod which does nothing
differently right now. Right. But one really important
thing when you're working with Kubernetes is that
sometimes you'll
actually want to get a bit more information.
So you can use the dash o flag,
which just means get me this pod information
in YAML and we can actually see a
lot more information about what is going on
underneath the hood here.
One other option we have is wide,
which just gives us again a bit more
information.
So
the dash o yaml one is
slightly more important because it's a really good
hacky way of then writing pod2.yaml
and then being able to generate fake resources.
But we won't cover that just now
because I'll end up rambling.
So
that's a pod. One or more containers, we
create the YAML, we apply it.
One thing is really important about pods
is that they are the lowest common denominator
or the primitive or the atomic unit of
what we make run inside Kubernetes.
However, what is really important is that this
is an immutable pods back. Pods cannot be
changed.
So if I were to kind of prove
that,
let's say I want to do NGINX two
or if that's Yeah. Let's do that NGINX
two
and then I try to reapply.
You can see here
that the pod NGINX is invalid spec forbidden,
pod updates may not change fields other than
container image
or active deadline seconds or tolerations.
So you cannot modify
anything particularly useful
about a pod directly.
Once it's running?
Oh, yes. Once it's been applied. Yeah. Even
if it failed, you still wouldn't be able
to modify it. So our only option now
would be to delete it. However, I think
that I guess there's one more important command
here.
We applied it. We created it. We done
a get pods. We can also run a
cube control logs
on our pods to pull out that log
information if we need to do any sort
of debugging to work out why something is
crashing.
Okay.
Alright. Let's delete that.
Delete it correctly.
Alright. When you ask you like a delete
command, it will wait
until that resource has been cleaned up, so
you may find that it just hangs there
for a little bit and it's
quite normal, nothing to worry about. It goes
away. We can then run get pods and
we're back to where we started.
Any questions on that little bit of surface
data that we touched so far? No. But
it managed to make this the fan spin
up on my laptop, so I'm wondering how
you did that because, you know, rocker.
Yeah.
Yep. Don't worry. Mine's just taken off too.
So Okay.
So we don't work with pods. I think
that's that's really important
as import
wordfuffle there. As important as understanding pods are
and as port as important as they are,
we never work with them directly. We have
other abstractions within the Kubernetes
API that allows us to work with them
in a slightly more manageable fashion.
Okay. So what I'm gonna do is just
create a new file
and call this deployment dot yellow.
So
when you first in fact, when you first
or even a thousand days into deploying to
Kubernetes, the deployment object as the de facto
right now for if you wanna take your
application and run it on Kubernetes, you use
the deployment spec.
It is a
super set of a pod that comes with
a controller that does loads of magic stuff.
Magic stuffs includes modifying or at least rotating
the pods when the spec changes, scaling up,
scaling down,
handling update strategies, all of that magical mystery
stuff that we're gonna try and cover.
I am using a Versus code plugin for
Kubernetes. That means I do not need to
take a lot of YAML for the common
resources.
So
that's why you can see it being templated
out like this. Yep. And I'm gonna use
engine x as a
a base for most of the stuff we
deploy today, because I think we're all familiar
with it, we know what it is and
there's no magic there.
I am gonna continue to remove this resources
block.
In fact, I'll do it one more time
to show why
it's kinda there. You can see all the
squiggles I get. That is my editor telling
me that you should not apply
a Kubernetes resource without resource management because it
could eat up all your resources.
So
I can kinda silence that to one line
while pushing an empty block.
And you'll see,
there's a couple of things different from this,
but still very very similar to what we
kind of played with with the pod. So
you can see that our
object key, the combination of API version and
kind has changed. Mhmm. The fact that this
has changed from v one to apps just
means that we've dropped out of the core
namespace, which is where the pod lives, and
we're now into an application specific namespace, which
is handled by a different seg,
the working groups and segs of Kubernetes project
all handled different API touch points.
The object that we're now deploying with is
called a deployment
and it still has some metadata that we
can apply to it. We still wanna be
able to name the object that we put
in the cluster. Okay.
Now
this bit here,
but this pod and container spec has not
changed. It's just slightly
deeper
and Right. The YAML structure. And what we
have here is the actual deployment spec and
the bottom bit is the pod spec within
the deployment spec.
So when we create a deployment, we're saying
we want to deploy this pod, but we
have some
we have some information that surrounds or encapsulated
that that is really important.
And the most important thing with the deployment
is something called labels and selectors.
Now,
I think it may be best
to apply this first and then double back
on the selectors when we have something running
that we can maybe take a look at.
Okay.
Okay. So
we applied that just like we did the
pod only this time, you know, it's got
a different prefix before it. It doesn't say
pod
and we can run get deployments
and we see something better similar to what
we had with our pod spec. Yep. So
we have the name. We still got one
of one containers.
Now we don't have something called the status.
We got up to date and available. We'll
talk about why this spec is a little
bit different.
But what's important is if we run get
pods,
you'll find that it does still create a
pod of bars.
It's just called it's it's just now a
managed
pod.
Right.
So it's got that it's got the
ugly string on the end of it
because it's managed by somebody else, something else.
Right?
Yes.
So this is a
three piece tuple,
and each segment in this tuple
identifies
a different layer of abstraction.
So let me try and explain how the
deployment actually works.
When you create a deployment,
it gets created on the cluster and nothing
happens.
There is a deployment controller that notices that
object and then it creates something called a
replica set.
Get replica sets.
And you can see the the now got
a two piece tuple. Yep. So so this
is the deployment name and then this is
the identifier for the replica set.
And then there's a controller that monitors the
replica sets and goes, oh, we need pods
and then this is the pod ID.
So we got this layer of command. Right.
Deployment creates
deployment
creates replica sets, replica sets create pods and
we create a deployment.
Now it's very confusing,
it can be
a little bit difficult to understand and that's
just to do with the way that Kubernetes
works, so that's controller model and people, know
the controls are only responsible for one really
small part of the API.
So disregard that unless you really wanna know
about it, we can talk about it later.
What we really care about is we created
a deployment and we get a pod out
the other side. If we just pretend our
view here is get deployments
and pods, you can just do a get
with a comma and it'll pull out multiple
types. Okay. So you can see we've got
our deployment,
we have our pod. Yep.
Okay.
Next.
Labels and selectors.
So
because I've already that it's good now that
I covered that that hierarchy of abstraction.
The deployment controller needs a way to know
which replica sets
it created.
The replica set controller needs a way to
know which pods it created, so that if
I delete the replica set, it deletes the
pod
and if I delete the deployment, it deletes
the replica sets.
These labels are used to do that matching.
At least they form a a base of
the matching.
So if I do a describe on deployment
NGINX.
Let's see.
You can see that this has a selector
that says all of the replica sets and
it doesn't say here replica set, but because
we've kinda covered that hierarchy we know. Any
replica set that says app equals NGINX is
gonna be controlled somehow by this resource.
I can then do a describe on the
replica set.
Excuse me.
And we should see our label as app
equals engine x. Yep. And of course, if
I do a describe all the way down
the tree,
we're gonna see
labels app equals engine x.
Labels are a way to identify how the
different layers of abstractions are actually owned or
controlled or operated etcetera.
Does that make sense? Yes, it does.
Awesome. Good.
Now because this is employment, we can modify
anything we want.
So let's keep the name the same. Let's
not confuse the the per Kubernetes
and
let's do
app engine x tutorial.
Now these do need to match up,
otherwise we're gonna have a mesh match in
the selector.
So if I say this and I try
and apply this, it should hopefully
complain.
Yeah.
So these do always have to match otherwise
you'll have resources that were created that were
not operated by their controller. Right.
And we can modify the containers. So say
that I don't want to run NGINX. What
about if I wanna run httpd?
So I'm gonna change that image
and I will change the name of the
container.
And while I'm here, just for good measure,
there are many other fields on the deployment
spec that we can change. The most important
one is the replicas.
What if I wanna scale this deployment? I
can set the replicas to five.
And if I apply this,
I broke it.
You changed the name.
So, yeah, these
bets are immutable because I'd already created the
deployment. So I'll cheat and just modify the
name to create a new resource.
And I will delete the old deployment
like so.
And we'll pretend that all worked.
So
deployments,
we now have this new one and you
can see that we're
we're starting to scale up.
So we have two available at five,
five available out of five. So
pretty quick. It doesn't take a lot of
effort to scale the service.
You can imagine if this was a production
thing and I want you to be able
to scale on demand or in reaction to
metrics or whatever.
It's as simple as modifying my YAML and
saying, I need more of these, please.
So you can modify the scale of it
in,
you know, at runtime, basically. Right? You can
add more or remove or remove them, and
it will scale appropriately?
That is correct. So let's assume we come
in here and we're like, alright.
We've weathered the storm, whatever magic event happened
on Twitter. We now can, you know, maybe
comfortably go back down to just having two
replicas.
We just reapply our deployment.yaml.
I'm gonna run a get pods with dash
w which just means watch and I was
too slow. I mean, it's already scaled that
resource down for me. So yeah.
So yeah. We can modify the spec and
that's just comes down to the way that
Kubernetes works. Whenever you apply NF into the
cluster, those controllers set in the background and
monitor the spec.
Whenever that spec changes, it goes out of
its way to do a reconciliation
loop and get the cluster into the state
that we declaratively define.
Which explains why you can't really change the
name in the
on a on a running cluster because then
it would
not understand what it's supposed to change, and
it would cause all sorts of
mayhem. That's a good a good point. I
had actually thought up of that change on
the selector on an existing deployment. It would
actually put you in a moment of flux
where it didn't know which resources to clean
up or create.
So if that makes sense. There are some
letter immutable fields across it, you'll have them
at one point or another and if you're
anything like me, you'll forget. But
we can
use test deployment spec now as a basis
for most workloads that we wanna deploy to
our cluster.
Okay. Any any questions on that or are
we happy? No. We're happy. And we can
add other services to that
that pod by just adding more containers to
the pod. Is that the idea? Or
now I'm really gonna confuse it.
No. So there are use cases. So this
is a really common pattern in Kubernetes called
sidecar.
Sidecar is generally
a name that we use for any pod
that has multiple containers.
Something that you may wish to do and
a better software that we're both familiar with
would be deploying Telegraph.
Mhmm.
So assuming we wanted to do
have a sidecar container, a Telegraph container running
next to our application and scraping metrics and
our Prometheus based pool sale operation,
then we could add a container like so,
and then I can just reapply this.
And what we're gonna see here is our
new one here has ready zero of two.
Now that just means that it's currently pulling
the telegraph image. Yep. I can run a
a watch on this with dash w and
it will work this time.
And we'll see that change as the image
pulls.
It's now spinning up the pods, so it's
now killing the old pods. So you know,
it spun up the new one the first,
waited until it was almost running, started tearing
down the old one and then the other
one gets terminated.
What we can do now is run get
pods and you see that we have two
pods, each with two pods both running and
happy.
So that is
this is a pattern
that is used to enrich or augment the
functionality of a container or application with some
other piece of functionality.
However, you would not use this pattern to
deploy every service in your application
as a single deployment.
What you would do is have multiple deployments.
So let's
let's add something then to this. Let's add
a new file, and we call this our
deployment two, very unique and original name.
Yep.
There
what image should we deploy?
We can just deploy NGINX
again.
But we'll give it a name that's not
NGINX. We'll just pretend. Because that image is
already in my cluster. I don't need to
pull anything new, which is Right. Really a
good thing.
So let's pretend this is some stateful database
application,
Oracle DB because you know, why not?
We'll call our selectors. We'll just make this
match as well,
so we don't have any conflicts. But we're
still just gonna deploy NGINX and then we're
gonna continue to pretend it's Oracle.
And I'm not going to expose any ports.
Alright. We will,
cause we're gonna show off some of the
networking functionality that we get with Kubernetes.
Okay.
So this is our second deployment.
It's Oracle DB and
we can apply it
in the same fashion.
We run get deployments
and pods.
And you can see that we now have
two deployments. We have our engine x tutorial.
We have Oracle DB.
Right. And we have our collection of pods.
Yep.
Okay.
Now
we
want this stuff to talk to each other.
We do. And I always have a hard
time with this with Docker
containers because it's like, well, that's running in
a Docker container. You can't talk to it.
I
wanna talk to it.
Alright. Let's see if we can make that
happen then. So
primitives were covered thus far are pods and
deployments.
There is another really important one called a
service.
And that service provides DNS
based discovery of the other services within our
Kubernetes cluster.
So it's called a service.yaml.
And we have auto complete, which makes my
life a lot easier.
So we'll expose
our
engine x one
and
we'll make it available on port 80. We
don't need to specify a target port as
long as I'm not getting this wrong in
my brain. The target port will default to
the port. So Okay.
What this channel says is I want a
service to exist called NGINX.
That name
will be created as a DNS resolution within
the cluster, so I can then query NGINX
as if it were a URL.
The selector is the same as what we
had in our deployment. So selector says
all of the pods that have this label
app engine x,
we will allow
to answer requests for the engine x service.
Okay.
So this could also based on our current
examples be Oracle DB.
Okay.
And we have to tell it which port,
so we can publish services on any port
that we want, port 80, port four forty
three, port 53,
whatever.
Because this is a web service, I'm gonna
export it on port 80 and
we can apply
Like so.
Now
what command do you think we run to
list the services?
Probably get services.
Yeah. It's not a trick question.
That's what I guess is is nice. The
entire Kubernetes API surface is mostly just the
restful API and then the commands that we
use to query that become very intuitive very
quickly.
Well, what we can see here is that
we have an NGINX service of type cluster
IP.
Cluster IP just means that it's gonna generate
an IP within the service IP range for
the cluster.
You can see here we got a 10Dot105Dot193Dot142.
Right. Right. Not exported externally and the port
that we defined is also there.
So if we want to see this working,
we can go inside of a port. So
very much like docker exec, we have the
ability to ability to do cube control exec
and I'll jump inside this Oracle DB container
and I have a bash shell here. Right.
Do I have curl?
I do have curl. Excellent. That makes my
life a little bit easier.
So I can do curl http
engine x.
No, I can't.
Alright. We may have our first
problem.
Ah, the labels were wrong. Okay. So now
we're into debugging a service. Okay.
Because when I created this deployment,
I updated these selectors with the new ones.
So my selector on the service, if I
split screen here. Yep. Is NGINX and not
NGINX tutorial.
Exactly.
Now the way you debug this in Kubernetes
is to describe our service.
Now what's important here
is our endpoints are none.
That's this is the first indicator that the
service you've created, you've made a mess of
it. Because it's not there's yeah.
There's no endpoint to the service.
Exactly.
So I'm never gonna be able to create
it. So we can fix that with
tutorial.
We reapply our service and before I even
query it, I'm just going to scrape this
thing again and right away we've got two
endpoints that are happy to answer that question
of can I speak to engine x? Yep.
Alright. So let's try that exec again.
Is my curl there? Yep. And you can
see if I curl engine x the service
name,
I get a response from our engine x
deployment pods.
Great.
And that works ubiquitously
across your Kubernetes cluster.
So why don't we tackle
the very explicit
DNS name that happens here.
Now it's not the NGINX as
a valid domain name. What is actually happening
here is that it's being completed by the
DNS within the cluster
to
s v c.cluster.local.
Like so.
And this is a predetermined
format that works in almost
every Kubernetes cluster. So this is the service
name NGINX, then we get dot followed by
the namespace,
which I know we've not covered yet,
followed by the resource type. So SVC is
just short for service
and then this cluster dot local is the
cluster domain name. Now most cluster ship with
cluster dot local. I think it's rare that
I see this changed. However, I guess it
is important to know that
it's not gonna be there a % of
the time. Whoever spends up the Kubernetes cluster
can pick anything they want. You can have
david dot lol cat or something. So
because
of the way the DNS resolution works, I
can query that
at each level. This is something in DNS
resolution called end dots it's configured within the
cluster. So
you got a lot of flexibility with service
discovery.
Now something that
something else that is really cool about this
because it's not cool enough that you get
DNS based resolution.
You also get rounds robbing
load balancing.
So so it's also doing the load balancer
as well as the because I saw that
it when you did the describe the service,
it had two endpoints. So it will basically
load balance between those two endpoints.
That is correct. Now let's visualize that.
Let's modify our image here.
No. So this is an image that exists
on the public Docker registry.
Is from the functions as a service project
open fast and
the node info name just means that this
container
will respond with whatever the host name is
called.
Now because of Kubernetes networking, the host name
is the pod name. You can see here
on the Oracle one that this is the
the name of my pod.
So
if I reapply
our deployment one,
we should see those all will be rotating.
Yep. So the first one's on its way.
Let's just watch.
It's pulling in that functions node info.
Now it's replacing the other two.
We just got one more to go.
Alright. We're good. So
these are now these two parts here are
running the node info.
Don't break. Okay. The node info image.
So I'm gonna jump back into Oracle and
just run this again. So we're gonna see
different output. This is no longer going to
be the output from NGINX or Apache web
server.
That was unexpected. Ah, the port has changed.
I never thought of that. Okay. So this
port is actually eighty eighty in that container.
Okay.
So now we need to target port.
So I'm still going to expose it on
port 80. I don't wanna change my curl
command.
Right. I want it I want it to
work like that. So now the target port
and the port are actually different. So we
just specify it like so.
So now I need to reapply
our deployment.yaml
and our service. And we can do that
in one line or with two dash f
flags. Okay.
We
shouldn't actually need to wait. That should all
restart
pretty quickly.
Quicker than that. Come on. I guess the
shutdown is actually what's making it take a
little bit longer than I thought it would.
I'll be patient.
I'm very patient.
Okay. So we got two new ones running
and the old one's shutting down, that's okay,
but we have these two which are twenty
seconds old.
So we go back into Oracle DB and
we can hopefully curl NGINX.
Perfect.
Yep. And it gives you the host name.
Yeah. So now we have the host name,
the platform, the architecture, how many CPUs are
available and the uptime.
And if I hit this more than once,
there we go.
You see the host name changed on the
third try. Now we've only got two two
pods.
So it did take a couple of tries,
but you can see we are getting load
balancing across those service endpoints. So another really
cool kind of quality
of life thing that you get for free
that used to be really difficult or,
you know, configure an h a proxy to
do, you know, the load balancing part. It
can be a little bit cumbersome.
This is nice. Right?
Yeah.
So my question about all of this is,
you know,
how much overhead am I adding with all
of this? I know that, you know, Docker,
at least on Docker Mac, is is just
a resource pig.
So am I am I adding a ton
of overhead to whatever I'm doing, you know,
just to get this this little bit of
niceness?
Yeah. I mean, there's no
there there is a cost. It's not free
of course. There are many, not many. There
are a few components that need to be
running on the the bare metal for this
to work.
The Docker for Mac is a slightly unique
situation and that because Mac doesn't understand container
primitives directly,
Docker for Mac does run a virtual machine
that virtual machine running is gonna be a
battery sync.
So
let's just talk about maybe the bare metal
experience rather than the Docker for Mac one
because I think that's that's just something we
have to live with if we if we
run Macs. So
on a bare metal environment, the overhead for
running containers
with Kubernetes
will be there is a cubelet process on
the machine,
which is responsible for start and stopping and
handling the containers.
There is
a cube proxy
or a CNI implementation.
So there is some sort of networking on
the machine that actually knows how to do
all the IP table manipulation.
So there's a cost there.
There is also
across the cluster, but not across every node,
there is API servers,
schedulers,
and
etcd.
Oh, and DNS. So those those four control
plane components which have to be scheduled somewhere,
if not on all the working nodes. Well,
probably not on all the working nodes, but
they have to be scheduled somewhere and highly
available. So there is a cost. It's actually
not too bad considering the things you get
for free.
Because if you were gonna do this manually,
I mean besides all the automation you would
have to write to dynamically
reconfigure HAProxy as services come and go.
This is probably a little bit cheaper,
but with the painful point of, well, shit.
You need to learn all this stuff now.
So,
you know, choose your battle.
Yeah. Yep.
Okay. So we covered pods. We covered deployments.
We have covered discovery
and load balancing across pods with services.
Now we've only looked at one service type,
which was the cluster IP.
That is the default, that is why there's
nothing in my YAML that says this is
cluster IP,
but you can pretend
that we had this line here, so that
is just the default. There are other service
types.
I don't think they're gonna be particularly important
for today. They are typically used to expose
services from the cluster outside of the cluster.
Okay.
How about
configuration?
So
what do we have running right now?
Okay. Let's do this. Let's change our functions
as a service back to engine x.
Oh, that's a good point. We could do
that too. Okay.
Sorry. Too many ideas.
I'll leave telegraph in. We change this port
back,
and we'll leave all that of it. So
really all I wanna do right now is
get
our
get our engine x
back to normal.
We'll give that a few seconds. So Okay.
What we're gonna do now is
we wanna inject some arbitrary information
into this NGINX
pod
so that we can change the behavior.
Right now responding with the NGINX
and hello
world style page or basic default page isn't
terribly useful.
So we wanna see how we can pass
in some sort of configuration to change that
behavior.
We may even just do that to configure
Telegraph to probe engine x or something like
that. But we we wanna show how we
can configure the the
processes running within our pods. Okay.
Now to do that, we need a new
resource type.
So let's call this config map dot yaml.
Config maps. And
we'll call this NGINX. Now config maps are
YAML definitions of key value pairs that live
inside of our cluster.
So I could have
username
Rawkode.
I could have index.HTML
and use YAML's multilane thingamajiggy to say hello.
I am
Rawkode.
And
if I want, I could do some sort
of list.
So I could do numbers
One,
two,
three.
Why is this yelling at me?
It is a string.
Why am I failing at YAML?
Because it's YAML.
This I
every time I think there's nothing wrong with
my YAML, I'm always proven wrong. So
the YAML linter is my friend.
My YAML is fine.
Mhmm.
Okay. I'm just gonna assume it's wrong and
Versus Code is just a little bit confused.
So
let's apply our config map.
And the type got an array is bit
oh, okay.
Yeah. It's right. I'm wrong. Config map key
value pairs cannot have sub types.
So let's just do numbers
like this.
Just me being silly.
Okay. So we can apply that. And now
we have something called a configuration map available
inside of our cluster. We can do get
config maps. We see engine x. We can
query engine x.
We can use the output toggle that we
were using earlier,
and we can see our data is now
stored here inside of our config map. Okay.
That is now in a position
where we can consume this within our pods
and deployments
and inject the inside of the containers.
And there are two ways we can do
this.
So
let's open
this.
What should we do first?
Let's do exposing
these as environment variables.
So we can do env from,
contact map reference,
give it the name of engine x.
So these three lanes here
tell our deployment that there is a config
map called engine x that we want to
expose as environment variables within the container.
Okay.
I can reapply my deployment.
And what we will do is just to
connect and to one of those pods.
That was just restarted.
Let's try again.
Oh, there's two pods.
Yeah. So sorry. There's two containers. You need
to specify the container name when there are
two. So dash c nginx and then run
bash. I was getting confused about which one
I wanted to run-in.
And that pod is away because that's the
one that
should just wait until all the pods have
restarted before I get inside of them, shouldn't
I? Alright.
So this ID has changed, so let's do
this. Okay. So now we've got a proper
pod name. We tell it which container and
we want to run bash.
Finally.
There you go.
We can run the e n v
command
and we'll see here
HTML
equals hello, I am Rawkode.
We have numbers equals numbers
and username equals Rawkode.
So now I have a way to dynamically
configure my application as long as it understands
environment variables.
So for things like if you were, for
instance, running a a database that had a
that you had to pass in a
a key
for
inserts,
you could run and they can get that
from an environment variable. You pass it in
there, and then all of the the various
pods
pick up that value. Right?
That is correct. Yes.
Now we have another option.
If we don't want if our application cannot
be configured through environment variables, we have the
ability to use a volume.
So in our deployment spec here, we can
see volumes.
We'll call this config.
The volume can come from somewhere.
So we can see here that it is
a config map
with the name
NGINX.
So this says define a volume called config
with the contents of the config map NGINX.
Okay.
Now that doesn't do anything
on its own. We then have to mount
the volume into the container that we want
to have it.
So
here, we can do volume mounts,
mount path, I'll call it config,
and the volume that we wish to mount
is config. Yeah.
Okay.
So now we can come back over here.
I love that when you just do one
of these introduction to Kubernetes things, it's just,
hey, look at all of this YAML. Yeah.
I'm
really sorry.
No. And I don't know whether it's really
scary or or
but it's actually starting to make sense. So
that should probably scare people that are watching
this because it's actually starting to make sense
to me.
Well, that's good. I'm glad that I'm not
just bombarding you with YAML. Okay. So we're
gonna go back inside one of our new
pods, not one of our old pods. And
just so I don't have the old one,
I will copy and paste. We specify the
container
and we specify the command. So we still
have our environment variables here.
Yep. However,
we should now have
this conflict directory.
Yep.
Where I can cat
each of those values
like so.
I know that's a little bit difficult to
see because it kinda happened in lane.
But, you know Yeah. There's a Rawkode at
the start of that and the numbers here.
Yep. And our multilane
string.
There.
So those are the
that's how we configure our pods with non
secret information.
There is something
very similar to a config map called a
secret,
which is kind of secret, but not completely
secret.
Okay. So
let's let's just
So we're calling it secret, but it's not
really secret.
Yes. Unfortunately.
So what I'm gonna do is
YAML allows us to do three dashes to
split one document into multiple types. I'm just
gonna use that here. I'm gonna copy the
config map,
paste it, and I'm just gonna change this
to be
secret.
I'm going to change
this to be string data.
I think that's enough.
We'll see. So let's reapply our conflict map
and we should expect to see a secret
created
like so.
So
why does my screen share keep tearing like
that?
There we go.
I am running Mac Big Sur. So, you
know You're inside your container there, so that's
probably not gonna work.
Good catch. Thank you. Alright. So
cool. So we reapplied that. Now you can
see our contact map is unchanged. We didn't
modify it. However, we did create a secret
there.
Yep.
We can run get secrets.
You can see our engine x one is
here.
I'm gonna pull out that one secret pass
and the negotiation.
So I'd say, hey, commit back in YAML.
And we have our secrets.
Uh-huh. Those do those strings look secret?
Not particularly.
No. This is our wonderful favorite encoding,
base 64.
So
secrets are not terribly secret. There are things
and stuff
one can do as a Kubernetes operator
to improve the situation. But by default, our
secrets are available to anyone with permission to
query them.
They're just sophisticated
through basics before.
And that is why we also specified string
data in this file.
It's better than Rawk 13, I guess. But
But whenever you see that equals sign, you
immediately know that I'm just gonna base decode
that and I've got access to whatever. But
yeah.
That's string data. If I had not changed
that to string data, if I had stuck
with data, this would have failed
because it's not base 64 encoded.
It would have said, hey, those values don't
look encoded to the way I want.
So we can pass them in a string
data. Of course, when it comes to secret
management,
there's a whole world of tooling and other
options for Kubernetes,
but this is what is baked down and
built in for free. The good news is
like you still do you still need authentication
to the Kubernetes API. You still need a
cube config that lets you do the query.
Things are encrypted on the the node machines
at rest,
so and in transit.
So there there's that plus.
But have you ever get access to the
cluster with this fashion, then your secrets are
compromised immediately. So Well, you know, physical access
is is game over for most things, so
in security land. So
That is true.
Alright. So
any questions before we start tackling a few
other bits and pieces? No. This is great.
I'm actually I'm I'm actually learning stuff and
and this is making sense. So
Alright.
When we spoke about the service DNS lookup
earlier, we mentioned something called a namespace.
So we'll just really really quickly cover what
that is. I don't wanna spend too much
more time on it. So
I don't wanna spend any time on namespaces
because they're super uninteresting.
But Okay. They're important to know. So
namespace YAML.
We have a yeah.
We have kind.
And this is the only one I can
ever remember how to type. So yeah.
Tada.
I bet you that doesn't apply now but
Oh,
metadata,
silly me.
I was right, didn't apply. So
namespaces are in the core v one group,
which is why it's just v one, the
kindness namespace, the namespace is called my namespace.
Much like every other object, I can tell
get namespaces
and we have our new namespace. Now Yep.
Everything that we have created thus far has
been created in the default namespace.
I can run get pods when I see
stuff and things.
Yep. And if I do get pods dash
in
my namespace,
no stuff in things.
Oh. But namespaces are a way to logically
group things depending on your own workloads
and configuration setup,
team dynamics, Conway's law, whatever you wish to
apply to that logical grouping is entirely up
to you. But namespace is a way to
encapsulate encapsulate that altogether.
What is funny though is you can
I can't delete the name? Yeah. You can
delete the namespace and it will blow away
all of the resources. There's nothing in my
namespace but it would have destroyed everything.
I didn't realize default was
Does it so what when you say it
destroys everything, that destroys the pods and everything
in it or just the namespace around it?
No. It should destroy all of the pods.
So if we do
let's just reapply this then. So let's copy
this deployment.
I mean, if I remember correctly, it just
it doesn't really care. So
we can specify the namespace and our metadata
and I can say deploy to my namespace
like so.
We'll reapply our
my namespace namespace with the deployment. We run
get pods by namespace.
I'll at least let them be healthy before
I try and kill them. So
I actually think I've
run out of resources.
So let's debug that.
The reason these I think these are stuck
in container creating
is if I describe the pod,
I think it's gonna tell me that it
can't allocate resources.
Namespace.
Oh, no. It's the contact map. Okay.
Oh, you're trying to mount the the the
config map from two different places?
That is correct.
So I'm just gonna copy in everything
just so that this applies.
Update the metadata.
I don't even think we did anything with
the secret, but I'll create it anyway.
We'll apply that once more. We'll run get
pods
and
yeah. So there's this also weird thing
where that pod is now stuck waiting for
something that didn't exist.
So you you kinda have to give it
a wee shiggle.
Give it a what? I need to hear
that again.
A wee shiggle.
Oh, okay.
That's dandy.
Just give it a wee a wee shiggle
and then it'll restart or so. You just
delete it, it comes back. Is this still
gonna fail?
Did I update all the right stuff?
I think it did. Oh, there we go.
Just me being impatient again.
So that that's now running.
And we look inside our my namespace again
and we call get secrets, we'll see our
secrets, we'll see our config map.
Like that's all what we expect and we'll
just delete my namespace
and it's away. It's now currently deleting that
secret, that config map, that deployment, that replicas
there and those two pods.
So, you know, careful with deleting namespaces. I
was gonna say, so deleting namespaces can be
extremely
destructive.
It can be. There's a concept in Kubernetes
called a a validating webhook.
What you'll find is most production clusters won't
allow you to issue a delete against the
namespace anyway
because of the validating webhook. They'll be like,
hey, are you really sure you wanna be
doing this?
So
alright.
So we've covered pods, deployments, contact maps, services,
and namespaces.
What else is fun?
Who was it the other day that posted
that they took out the entire web service
for some
application for the entire country of Norway because
YAML
misinterpreted
the word no in their YAML file.
Hi. That's one of my biggest gripes with
YAML is its ability to take billion logic
from anywhere it wants. No. It's just true.
False zero one is infuriating.
Yeah. But I hadn't read that story. You'll
need to share that with me.
Now I'm sure I'm forgetting stuff. We'll call
it
pressure.
However, I do have a workshop that I've
given before and I'm gonna see
what I would cover in that. So we
did pods.
We didn't do port forwarding, so we can
take a look at that.
We did deployments.
We did a little bit of port forwarding
when you when you pushed
one port to you exposed one port as
a
80 max to eighty eighty.
Yeah. That that is true. You're right. So
oh, the big nasty world of R back.
Don't know if I wanna touch that on
the stream.
Alright. So let's see. Let's come back to
our configuration
here. So we have this deployment dot YAML.
Let's spin this back up again.
Yeah. Let's do that and then we'll do
something with that telegraph container, so we can
see the
the cool perks from having multiple container pods
and why they're useful. So
but we still have that running, don't we?
Cool.
Yes. That's still running. So there's a command
we can use on the on the command
line configuring,
called port forward,
where we can specify the name of a
pod
followed by a host container port triples.
So on the left hand side of this
colon, we say this is the host port
we want to expose this pod on and
we want to forward traffic to the Container
Port 80.
Okay.
And that's really good for
one to actually hack your application from your
own machine.
So I can just fire open a browser
now. Yep. Go to local host on Port
8080, and it pushes me through to the
container Port 80 where NGINX is greeting me
with his welcome hello world estail page. Yep.
Alright.
So let's try and do something with this
telegraph now.
Now the one of the coolest things about
containers within a pod is that they share
the same
TCP stack.
What does that mean? Right. Let's
go inside
NGINX.
Only I'm not gonna end NGINX. I'm gonna
go into telegraph
container
and I'm gonna run bash.
I don't think I'll have p s. Oh,
I do. Okay. So we can see here
we have pad one which is telegraph,
doing this telegraphy thing. And then
my two processes here. Yep. There is no
engine x running in this container.
However,
if I do a curl on local host,
we do get NGINX back.
So this is to do with the containers
within the pods sharing
the same TCP stack.
Meaning that they both respond on local host
provided that
don't try to open the same port, otherwise
things will start to break.
So the reason
I like this sidecar pattern
is the telegraph in theory could be configured
to fetch metrics from NGINX on local host
without
because this doesn't actually go over a TCP
stack. It's using the networking within the container,
so there's no overhead of opening a TCP
socket and blah blah blah. You know, it's
it's a lot simpler than that.
So in theory, we could create a config
map
which tells Telegraph to use the NGINX plugin
on local host and go and fetch the
status page from NGINX and then spit out
metrics to
to somewhere.
There's quite a lot of of benefit there.
Okay.
Let's
cover
one more
primitive of Kubernetes
and we'll
see if there are any questions and then
I think we will be
done.
Maybe.
We do have a comment from Rick Brown,
a former colleague of David and I's.
He has sworn at Yamal for years. It
still doesn't make sense.
Yamal is the devil we're stuck with, not
the one we have to enjoy, unfortunately.
I don't think I've ever spoken to anyone
who's been like, yay, Kubernetes. I get to
write more YAML. I just
YAML fatigue is real.
Yes. It is.
And pretty much everything these days is is
now turning to YAML.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying. YAML. YAML. YAML.
Okay. So the the
the last primitive, I think, is important for
today. I mean, we have covered a large
chunk. Like, see, if I were to say
your average Kubernetes consumer
or developer,
the API touch points that they're gonna use
within the cluster is 95%
deployments
with a sprinkling or dash of conflict maps
and secrets.
And There's not really much more to go
into there. Now there are few things on
the deployment we can dig into with regards
to liveness probes.
We can maybe cover that. But there is
one more
primitive here
that is useful,
And that is a daemon set.
So I'm gonna deploy
telegraph.
Now we don't need
replicas and there's a reason for that.
We do still need our selectors.
Let's
remove that.
I'll get this to a stage where I
think there's a a slim hope that it'll
work and then we can go through it.
I'm not confident of course.
So alright.
I don't think, can't remember the API version
and maybe apps v one or it may
just be v one. We'll find out for
trial and error and fire. We do not
need a replica because a daemon set
deploys
one instance of the spec on every node
within a cluster.
Okay.
That makes sense. Replicas
is a few tail.
When I say nodes in the clusters, we
can run get nodes. That's just docker for
desktop, so I only have one node.
So this should run one telegraph d s,
which is a telegraph image with no configuration.
Assuming
the API version is right, which it is.
Perfect.
Well done. So now
I can run and get pods
and you see
we have this.
So
the parent object is different. It's no longer
a deployment, but it still has a similar
level of
abstraction to the point where eventually a pod
is created.
However, we can run get daemon sets and
we can see here that we have one
desired because we have one node and we
have one available.
So a daemon set is the kind of
process you would run,
know, telegraph as a really good example because
you probably wanna get hardware
metrics or bare metal metrics, node based metrics
from every machine in the cluster, CPU, memory,
failed size, all that kind of stuff.
And a daemon set would be the definitive
way to do that in the Kubernetes world.
So maybe
I'm getting this wrong, but it seems that
a daemon set is basically,
like, run this run this daemon on each
container in the cluster. Right?
Exactly. I run this container in every node
in the cluster. Right. Okay. Yeah. Yes.
Okay. Cool. So
I don't think there's much more to cover
in today's session.
I think I'm happy with that. I am.
Actually, this I learned a this has been
great.
I'm hoping it was useful for somebody that
was watching as well than, you know, watching
me be dumb,
which is entertaining in and of itself, I'm
sure. But
Yeah. I mean, I I think what I'll
kinda caveat this session with and that, you
know, this is not
you've learned
everything there is to know about Kubernetes because
obviously the the details and the intricate nature
of some of the components goes much deeper
than this.
But this is, know, if you were to
start developing against Kubernetes tomorrow, this would be
enough to get you working and not banging
your head off of too many walls.
Right. Just working with deployments, contact maps. I
mean,
that is most of the the thing you're
doing. Now there are things we could get
into. We could talk about helm package manager
in Kubernetes
for deploying third party applications, you know, not
your own code to Kubernetes.
Then there's a whole other world of stuff
we could cover there. There's then the day
one and day two stuff. There's security, performance,
management,
RBAC. Like, there's so much stuff. But because
I didn't notice overwhelm.
I did notice that all that stuff was
running as root, which is probably not such
a great idea
if you don't have to run it as
root.
Yeah. So all of the containers are running
by root, is an ideal. There's things like
security to context and the seccomp we can
get into.
Not only that, but, you know, every Kubernetes
command I've run is as a cluster admin
of this cluster. I'm not I'm
not taking advantage of leveraging the role based
access control within Kubernetes to restrict my access.
So I cannot delete a namespace with every
resource in the world under it. So and
although this was never meant to be a
guide to everything Kubernetes. This is Yeah. E
commerce guide to Kubernetes to get people and
yourself comfortable enough to deploy those
primitives that you use day in and day
out. And I think what we've covered is
a really good representation
of those challenges and Yeah. Our our tasks.
This is great. This has been awesome.
Alright. Do you have any final questions before
I let you get back to your day?
Not that I can think of.
This has been super fun.
Alright. Well, thank you very much for taking
the time out of your day and joining
me and letting me just throw loads and
loads of Yamal at you. I know it
must have been extremely uncomfortable, but I do
appreciate your time. It was a pleasure. Yeah.
It was a pleasure. No. I learned a
lot. Thank you. Thanks for taking the time.
Cheers, David. I will speak to you soon.
Have a good day, everyone. Bye. Bye.